are you garbage if your tux has a stain
on it and you wear it anyway then when
you get to the wedding you immediately
spill something on yourself in front of
a crowd to make it look like it happened
there so everybody is nonetheless
I respect the [__] move [__] what
are you doing off
he gets there someone get me meatballs
fat Dan get your tickets for all the
cities on the stay trashy tour and are
you garbage.com welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
new favorite podcast this is are you
garbage oh yeah it's that little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find it at the group to be classy
yeah or they're just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave Foley coming at
you on a beautiful day we're out back
here at hoodies in the new edition she's
upstairs with a nice shepherd's pie in
the oven okay in honor of our special
guest she also hid the silverware Mike
is coming at you from right next to me
he is the CEO of Ru garbage he's
assaulting of the suburbs baby give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what up gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
iTunes oh Video available on YouTube as
you know those numbers are true to roof
cooking and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there and you get bonus content
coming out the Wazoo gang it's all on
there check it the frick out yes sir and
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man makes us all look good works the
ones the twos the threes and the fours
he crosses the t's and he dots the eyes
give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins Toby
McMullen everybody hey what up dudes
what up pal nothing feeling like I just
found a four-leaf clover in the field
you know this one's angry though
this one's got a bit of an attitude
problem
he doesn't have a pot of gold he has a
pot of shut the [__] up I got a knuckle
sandwich for you
dang the long hair ain't lying because
we couldn't be more excited to have our
incredibly and I mean incredibly special
guests back with us again today first
time here in the new edition here at
hoodies uh you know him you love him
he's going to be at Helium Comedy Club
September 20th to go [__] show up and
see the kid and he's also got a brand
new special out right now 30 minutes
with Colin Terrell give it up for column
Turtle everybody
thanks guys
I'm pretty sure that's a girl's Jersey
I've just I've supported I've been a
Philly fan so long yeah oh man I've had
this since I was a young boy man he can
Pander I love when the Eagles hit those
home runs
Jalen hurts with a three-pointer
you look like a red shirt freshman right
now yeah nice no I think I look good
this is solid you know what I mean sure
looks good where did you get that
sorry sorry
you look like the third string
quarterback it looks like The Waterboy
September 28 helium Philadelphia
all jokes aside tickets are light
what can I say I love hockey I don't
know
yeah flyers or whatever you guys are I
love them I just picture you with a
closet full of jerseys for different
sakes you're just wherever this [__] is
I wish Boise had a team
plenty of ticket alert going over in
Boise no I'm just having a job
I'm just jammed up you know
how do you mean you start doing fentanyl
I respect this selfless promotion as a
businessman myself this is all time oh
that's some good water
oh yeah
if you have a problem with this you can
see me
I'll tell you about running Helium
Comedy Club if you show me one valid
ticket stuff if you find me I'll give
you a free ticket buddy congrats on the
special thank you let's go
um please give it a look if you're um at
home thank you it's out right now it's
out right now got a YouTube page he's
one of the best in the city he's you
know he's a little rough and tumble but
it's good he's a little [__] he's a
little edgy is this I guess I guess I'm
a dirty little Edge Lord yeah yeah it's
great though man congratulations showed
up in a bathing suit in a jersey yeah I
don't I've gone numb because because the
lead up to the special you're just
watching back the edits so often that
it's almost like it's like when you
repeat a word over and over and over
again it loses all I mean it's like my
face has sort of just become like I'm
like who is this yeah like I don't when
I see myself I'm like who is this
[__] did you hate yourself yeah of
course yeah what I'm not like myself for
the first time in my life I'm gonna
watch my spatula that's that's really
turn it on in your 30s that's that's the
moment when I watch my okay special
practice in self-love baby now it was a
lot of fun shout out guys just watch all
the specials actually you know you got
Louis Dave Smith George Jensen which
verse Kurt Metzger and they're all part
of a series of 30 minutes with gas
digital so I'm happy to tell first one
and let's hopefully hopefully it makes
me super famous there you go
you'll be bumping sigura it's Carly T
dude oh we gotta go we gotta kiss the
ring Kali T called me oh here's a
question yeah it's a lot of rings uh
yeah yeah they're popular with men in
Ireland right no yes thank you God damn
it they wore one dude no you did not
what did he did did you have a face in
the right way so that people know you're
ready to mingle
he's hanging out at the Docks trolling I
don't know if you noticed but it's
actually important for the tuna boats
that come in yeah yeah oh I forgot about
that he was dead set because I made fun
of him for it yeah and he was dead I was
young I was in love oh now the
narratives really changed sure no tough
irish guys wear it I thought Irish guy
three finger cluttering yeah
it comes with a track suit
um yeah I thought they were only like a
woman thing I didn't know it was like
we're both in a relationship let's wear
matching rings really as far as my
understanding is because also a lot of
this Irish stuff isn't I know in my
culture it's like you come over here and
it's American Irish yeah yeah there's no
corned beef and cabbage yeah no there is
yeah there's definitely corn beef and
cabbage there is yeah there's corn beef
plenty of alcoholism oh yeah yeah plenty
of domestic violence that crosses the
pond all of that stuff is that's genetic
the other stuff the other stuff
accessories the other stuff is cultural
that's like within that's in the DNA is
to be a booze bag but as far as I know
you put the ring on yeah and you you
point it towards you if you're if you're
no the heart goes towards you if you
like guys
[Laughter]
no it goes towards you if you're in a
relationship and out if you're looking
yeah yeah okay yeah you're looking I'm
watching you're cruising did you when
you like did you break open your girl
and go like this right in front of them
turn around no I tried there I tried to
pawn it oh yeah how much are they it was
a real eight bucks bro they're like
aren't they like fake I think I got 750
for it
I was in the throes of a drug addiction
and I was broken-hearted
how old were you when you weren't I
thought you were about to say you were
12. this was uh you were I was in my 20s
oh my early 20s yeah I thought they were
popular
yeah there was there was a couple of
comments where people wrote in were like
yeah I also wore one but I don't you
know I honestly but I'm also very bad at
this stuff but I never even knew them
until I moved to America really but
that's not to say because a lot of this
stuff I got we don't have that Island
then everyone's like yeah we do yours
and [__] yeah I never noticed anything
I had the same thing if you got married
would you walk a rocker would you rock a
wedding band
[Laughter]
a hooker stole it
I got I got one more shot at losing
these 20 pounds and see if that works
out if that were if that don't work out
I'm putting one on no I never wore I
didn't I don't know I I forgot we had
the wedding I forgot we were so many
things I forgot to get a ring because
it's like so not important to me yeah so
I got one on Amazon you got hers right
yeah we got hers I got one on Amazon for
like eight bucks just to have at the
ceremony I was like I'll get one later
but I can't I don't know I think I don't
wear watches I don't wear anything Rings
the rubber one seems a little black
robot one yeah really yeah people wear
Robo ones because a lot of construction
workers because like yeah you know
something will get cut on it yeah look
hot on it or rip your finger off but if
you work in a kitchen if you work in a
kitchen or not like that
[Music]
I once snuck into a music festival right
sure okay because and so what I did was
I got I got someone else to rip off
their hand armband The Wristband from
inside they brought out to me and I
printed up a fake ladder from my boss
and said I was here yesterday I came
home to do the night shift in the
kitchen I'm not allowed to have anything
on my hands in the kitchen so I had to
cut it off and they're like this is my
boss that says the rules that in the
kitchen signs and then yeah yeah exactly
put a little marinara sauce on it to
make it look authentic great guy
character ladder you know yeah yeah yeah
he was dressed like Chef Boyardee he
would never sneak yeah I don't think you
should have had a big mustache I was in
the meat
did it work yeah the guy was like great
because everyone else was trying to
sneak in there thank you for your
service sir
they were screaming at them going like
this crazy I can't believe it and I was
like man you must have a tough job I
walked in like dude these guys are
animals
here's a letter from my big boss yeah
level working guys like us huh
[Laughter]
talking about you wrote me a fake letter
so I get my first apartment I did he was
also dude his little that's that's
standard practice come on I'm trying to
level the plane come on quit doing that
he [__] he's like I don't know it was
right when he was trying to get his own
apartment I'm like you know uh he's like
yeah I need a letter for my employer
stating I make this much money I'm like
dude I'll make it ahead of the [__]
the head of podcasting what are you
talking about I'll sign whatever I'm
like send me what you need [__] head
of Pediatrics Toby makes 18 million
dollars a year I do I do I love a
[__] fake letter of course a fake
letter and back in the day when you had
to put three references then you give
your you you say hey your brother your
mom your sister yeah dude your brother
your mom your sister yeah always man
always yes he worked for me for five
years he's a great guy I did that [__]
all the time I got caught by a landlord
one time when I was trying to get my I
was I was living my buddy and I was
trying to move out and get my own
apartment by myself uh from with me and
my wife at the time my girlfriend she
was my now wife I'm panicking I swear to
God no ring no ring that's in my head
now dude she's like I heard you you know
um so she gets you a cluttering yeah it
makes me wear it oh I'm gonna [__]
nice
put that in her ear um he's been really
asking me something he really likes but
uh I had my my roommate who owned the
apartment
right as my current landlord which like
there was never any lead I was just
giving him like for 500 bucks a month
but theoretically he was theoretically
he was but he printed it up on like a
letterhead and was like you know he's
always paid his rent on time and all
this stuff and I sent it to my new
potential landlord he goes would your
buddy make this I was like no no no it's
a real company you know he's like it's
to be on
be honest handwritten on a pad yeah he
got he snuffed it out right away yeah
have you ever been the reference for
like a job reference have you ever been
like gotten the phone call we were like
yeah Toby worked for me for a long time
I don't think I ever did you've gotten
yeah I've gotten that call for yeah
buddy of mine I didn't I was in the
person's boss and he's like hey a fake
call yeah the fake Call yeah because
they got fired for doing something
stealing or whatever the [__] it was Hey
listen I'm gonna give these people your
number [__] absolutely that's an
acting job to me what do you know I can
do an Australian accent hello mate
you're talking to him you're yelling at
a fake secretary at least to hold my
call I'm on with the general manager of
Applebee's at the moment
yeah yeah yeah yeah he worked at me with
in Trader Joe's for a while yeah it's
pretty busy down well I think they're
only like Factory sound music they're
only legally allowed to ask if they did
work for you and how long yeah they
can't yeah people were like yeah they
[__] suck you're allowed to say they
were and everybody got another job if
that was the case yeah I know I know in
Ireland there's a real they say would
you rehire them
you're not listening I think that's
pretty good though that's fair I think
would you rehire them no because most of
the time the answer is going to be [__]
no that's not my fault you're a bad
employee you [__] bum yeah get your
[__] together and start with
contributing also if you are hiring
someone and then you ring their
reference and then the reference gives
them a bad reference you got this person
it's not even a bad reference it's like
you're too stupid to get out like to
allow this to happen you should have put
it should have put somebody who was
gonna at least give you a neutral lie to
me someone who eyes and gets their
friend to do it is actually I'd rather
have them than the [__] who gives a
hustler yes yes of course it's a real
good kid it's a real scam artist myself
absolutely that's all right um we are
planning one of the our next patreon
goal at the moment is uh
when we hit 12 500 [__] we're going
back Colleen we're going back he's never
been never been what are some things we
should do or places we have to see we're
obviously gonna hit the big ones we're
gonna do Dublin Dublin party go check
out the pubs see some uh I guess go see
some stuff I guess you know
the Dublin
Dublin's I've spent time double School
Dublin's a good deal yeah it's a regular
City it's like a European city so you
just go see the go to the pubs all the
old pubs are the ones you want to go to
all the pubs are like because there's
pubs from the 1800s are the beers cold
over there are they serving them warm
what's the deal cold cold yeah and even
Guinness is um does it looks rumored
again this is like some room temperature
but it's not never been a big Guinness
guy no it's different over there it's
unbelievable really Chris truly is yeah
you have one and like it's like like you
want to put cereal in it in the morning
it's so good yeah unbelievable when you
go to drink the way you think you get to
drink it you think you're gonna take a
Gulp and the next thing you know you're
emptying like I guess we're having
another one and then and then and then
the cream this is because I'm a real
Guinness snob too it's like a real bad
character trait but you see the like the
cream like riding the glass sticking to
the side of the glass you don't get that
over here because they wash it with the
wrong soap or whatever but uh it's legit
it's legit yeah okay yeah West sorry
good West Coast as well I think just go
west Coast go see the the open green the
Rolling Hills that's like the the
postcard version of it it's also
beautiful anywhere out there Cliff some
more all that type of stuff is there
anything to do other than just go look
at it just drink and man yeah and that's
why I I also it's an all-time booze bag
it's like yeah go to the bar look at the
field I will tell you bring a six-pack
because those fields get interesting
after about four or five beers feel like
throwing rocks at sheep
you guys ever handle a Car Bomb
I I will say Ireland has great tourism
because it's all built around booze so
even if you go to like the Jameson
Factory
um it's like it's just a museum but they
give you Jameson the whole time yeah
you're just like Twisted yeah you just
get wasted yeah yeah and the whole thing
Guinness is like that and there's loads
of a bunch of the walking tours and all
the ways you're just hammered the whole
time and you're like all museums should
just be like drunk museums I have no
interest in seeing a museum ever and I
know it's ignorant I I want to do when I
go to somewhere else I want to do what I
do at home and that's drinking about so
like I want to drink at a German bar I
want to drink it in an Italian Bar I
want to drink in an Irish bar that's
what I want to do sit in my underwear
and yell my wife
column stores like if you see a guy
named Patty osullivan he owes me 500
bucks against his ass
I thought when we were
[Laughter]
we were in crawl and the guy who was
hosting it I guess was a dork and like
two local bullies from his childhood
just stood there and made fun of him the
whole time dude it was insane
it was like guys please leave and
they're like shut up you [__] uh
they're like remember what you [__] your
pants in third grade dude
Jesus Christ oh it was one of the [__]
did we show them where your girlfriend
dumped you over in the corner yeah
where's your collateral ring [__] yeah
it was fantastic now that Trip's on the
rule no one no one's ever told me they
had a bad time in Ireland yeah and
that's why everyone always asked me for
advice I go trust me you're gonna have
fun and I have like a copy and paste
email that I sent to everyone people are
always asking me where to go I was like
just here you go here's it should you do
like Belfast should we is that if you're
no okay all right if we just got into
some political territory here oh you
want to use across International borders
[Laughter]
they'll hate that a lot of people don't
hate that and you know what the Brits
aren't funny
petrol bum petrol bum they say they call
it in Ireland yeah not a Molly an
appetizer what are we talking about here
is it just a Molotov cocktail yeah but
uh yeah I guess you could go up there
done is really beautiful I think Belfast
would be kind of a way so it's like a
bookie
[__] into Donnie golf for about three
stacks yeah the D was looking for you
I'm sorry Mr Gold I'll have your money
right away
let's get behind on the ponies
I thought the Eagles played basketball
there's something I took 120 points
I tried to tease it down I got it to
118. this episode is brought to you by
better help uh-huh racing thoughts are
the worst as we all know I got ones
racing through my head at light speed
constantly reminding the stupid things
that you did five years ago are making
an existential crisis on you at 3 A.M
when you're trying to get some shut eye
a great way to loosen those thoughts is
to talk through them in therapy with
better help yeah better help is totally
online convenient flexible suited for
your schedule uh you can do appointments
my phone video call or even by message
to make therapy work for your lifestyle
I've set up once I set up 15 billion
times big proponent of talk therapy it
just helps you get some stuff out you
get a different perspective on it half
the time as those thoughts race into
your brain you got to go poop to have
someone go what are you doing you're
nuts get out of here go take a walk go
walk to the park go go breathe in the go
get some sun breathe in a nice park day
or something you know what I mean and
you're not driving your friends crazy
with your craziness yeah okay well you
need help on that getting started is
easy take the short quiz to get matched
with a license therapist if your first
ever purpose isn't willing Don't Panic
you can swap therapists with the click
of a button which is a big thing it's
easy if you're hesitant going to sit
somewhere talk to somebody this just
gets you in the pool baby and then you
can decide who you want to swim with uh
it's basically like Tinder but for your
mental health all right now you know you
don't like him you keep it moving yeah
uh get a break from your thoughts with
better help visit betterhelp.com garbage
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help h-e-l-p.com garbage
do it gang okay let's talk about trust
and Will shout out to them gang spoiler
alert we're all gonna die eventually and
you don't want to have all your stuff
written down at some notepad next to
your deathbed do yourself a favor get
over to trust and will you're a real ray
of sunshine do yourself a favor get over
to trust and will and plan this out it's
a 21st century uh-huh you can easily
manage your will or Trust online with a
click of a button you can Pawn your
stuff and even your kids off to someone
else and get it all finalized by a
notary I like that there you go I
actually recently set up a will it's
fantastic gives you a little bit of
Peace of Mind you set it and forget it
what am I getting what just getting a
visit from the [__] fence this is all
in your name pal uh each will each will
or trust will be made State specific and
customized to fit your Needs Trust the
will even secures your information with
bank level encryption so your important
documents are safe and protected there
you go if you ever need help with the
process uh Live customer service to
support through phone chat and email
right here here's the turkey gain peace
of mind today with trust and will get 10
off plus free shipping with your estate
plan documents by visiting
trustingwill.com garbage that's 10 off
and free shipping at trustandwill.com
garbage do it gang yeah do it uh aren't
the horse races big over there oh yeah
huge yeah go see the ponies yeah the
ponies will go to big day out but it's
very well you got to get dressed up it's
like a whole like everyone thinks
they're like you gotta put on your
nicest jerseys yeah
it's like you're going to a wedding
almost like you know that's what we
should go I like that I would do that I
like that if you timed it with the
Galway races that'd be particularly
great yeah that'll be very very good the
dogs are great too but I guess it is
frowned upon probably got to the dogs
anywhere is it no it's you can't dog
track they're not in the US anymore dog
tracks are fun night out what daily do
they still have that down in Florida
they got the Greyhound I think yeah I
think they got rid of them right or
there might be one left or there I know
they were in the process of shutting
down or getting all shut down I wouldn't
want to see that nice doggies they're
built they were designed to run fast and
be whipped and stuff they were designed
to be smacked with a shovel if they
don't win that was like they were bred
to do that so it's like that's part of
their DNA there's only two left and
they're in West Virginia that ain't good
yikes I don't have my passport on me
[Laughter]
[__]
then risk it with a [__] dog race in
West Virginia
um all right but all right so uh let's
get into some [__] questions here
gang
that was a nice little segments
uh guys when you sign up for the patreon
we will answer your garbage question on
the air and we are closing in on that
latest uh goal of 12 500 Peeps and we
will go to Ireland nice I mean we'll see
over there we'll time it when you're
over there why are you gonna be over
there I'm always over there all the time
I'm the commuter also I could see us
going to a bar with you and like
dragging us into some old beef that you
have we're like sure you like you know
rabbit punched a guy back in the day
yeah Susie walked in and I go no no no
I'm good
oh yes
[Laughter]
now let's see if he's running your mouth
with my boys here yeah I got my knee
brace on I walk in I got like I tell him
this is a nice little quiet joint as
soon as I walk in Paddy I just got a
glass break I told you I'd be back all
right one time I walked into a 7-Eleven
in Chicago with my buddy and the guy
started by the counter started losing
his mind I told you get out and we got
up front I was like what was that he was
like I got drunk I pissed all over the
taquitos
you thought we could go back
I do love shout out to a taquitos love
it tequila the guilt the Catholic guilt
you wake up the next day having one of
them I mean that I could I could finish
out they don't bother me at all oh that
that's like a late night 4am give me one
of those things that's been rolling for
a week you know what he likes he likes a
wingy
[Music]
when it comes to food too I'm a sloppy
mess you don't really want to be near me
really I'm so refined in this country
yeah and people apparently I didn't even
notice but apparently when I eat I don't
know where I put my arm around my food
like this and I eat like I'm in prison
like it's my first I didn't know until
like people like them dating me like are
you in a hurry or something like I'm
gonna have them it's like the bowls ring
I'm a pig yeah you're not a sharer when
you eat are you oh yeah if you and if
you and if you and the bird go out
you'll share an appetizer yeah I want to
taste everything so you can taste
whatever whatever yeah I'll share
whatever I'm not bad with that at all
well you don't do it how about you jobs
you probably won't let me share a little
bit more
now I like that I liked it I like the
community appetizers yeah yeah no I'm
like that with all food sure sure give
me a bite give give a bite yeah oh cause
I just want to bite of every single
thing on the menu will you eat after
somebody's Fork like if we if you and I
were out to dinner would you use my Fork
I I would but I know it probably looks
bad so I'd probably be like I'm not
doing that but I honestly couldn't care
less no I'd speak if I took that lady in
the Trap
you guys are splitting a chicken wing if
I took a bite of a burger and gave you a
bite would you take a bite of that yeah
Kippy
you just had absolutely not I don't even
like eating burgers in front of you
let alone let alone go and tit for dad
on a bird I mean I'm pretty gross but
[__] a bite of a sandwich a bite of a
sandwich is all right it depends on the
sandwich really I'm surprised I mean
what like to share a bite is like if I
had a sandwich not you I said other
people Toby Toby had a column column
probably my problem with you two is you
guys got a lot of hair around there's a
lot of hairs getting on that sandwich
that [__] Mayo mustache yeah man
and you are unaware yeah
who puts Mayo on a chicken horn do I
take a bite
oh man that's gross yeah that's the pro
it's a mouth thing yeah for me I got you
you know what if it's like you think I
have a gross mouth
that next question
it's not it's not dry enough to share
dude sounds you know it's like a Komodo
dragon
also sometimes I look over it and you're
just lick you're licking your hair
you're going oh yeah I do I chew on my
beard a lot yeah in the corners I like
to put a hair in my mouth and then I
just pull it out with my teeth nasty
yeah ugh weird uh but I've shared like I
share a sandwich with uh you know who's
big on that it's Tommy Pope does the
bite for bite oh Tommy doesn't feel like
a bite and be like oh you gotta taste
this and I don't mind that Tommy you
want to kiss him now I know that I'm
trying to get close to him I'm just I'm
not even hungry yeah
I shouldn't but okay
become allergic to Seafood whatever you
got Benadryl
tell me whatever you say Tommy kiss me
I've got an email uh
all right but let's get into it let's
get into some goddamn cues here gang
sure
um this is from hot boy soup five dollar
homie never had one red I'd like to get
the international take on this in
elementary school did you wear an NFL
jersey to picture day I rocked a Dan
Marino Jersey in fifth grade I want one
I want to know what your school picture
days were like did you do that like the
yearbooks and stuff uh no no we don't we
there's no yearbook there's no yearbooks
no Loveless Loveless
remember that time
everybody's got black eyes
someone from the same family every
single
so what did you do school pictures or
like one big picture we did oh there was
the yeah there was photos they were
paintings yeah I feel like they're all
black and white and you're all covered
in Coal I've got a standing outside of
an abandoned bungalow
uh we did have end of year photos it
never went into a yearbook it would be
like you would take a home for your you
would have it at the house like on
display yeah but it was it was always in
like a cheap like almost cardboard yeah
like a paper thing and then you had a
class photo where you'd all Stand
Together God there was no you had to we
all had uniforms so I knew it in public
school you wore uniforms uh right yeah
yeah yeah so that's the standard
um honestly it's the private schools
that we don't wear uniforms which I
think is backwards here right yeah yeah
yeah it depends that did remind me
though I used to I love the senior class
picture where you were everybody was
down in the in the gym and everybody got
up and they were like let's do a goofy
one yeah whatever yeah jockeying for
position and that was was big who you
were sitting with where you know what
the social structure showing off your
colada ring I'm available hi guys I'm
looking uh I never had a big we never
got really dressed up did you get like
dressed up for school pictures senior
year yeah a senior year it was big
senior a big one the senior one is yeah
because that's my senior class picture
right back there with the Paisley tie
you're blonde
no no no that's you you know when you
play football yeah surprised he hasn't
told you you gotta get that job dude
that's a that's a you have a great job
I'm working on it is supposed to get me
a Jaws or something coming in look I
want to wait waste of a great jaw look
at that jaw I was pushing it out
All-American Superman I would do that
when I was a kid I'd push it out to look
better did you have uh nope so I think
we did a confirmation and communion
you'd have your photos and I don't think
we ever did any of the photos but I am
curious about your I was for the priest
did you have a you had a high school
sorry no I talked over that was my bad
uh we did have a quote I was gonna bring
that up I had a real yeah oh [__]
douchebag oh you ruined it
dude guys worked on that for like two
years oh you were like this is gonna
mine was a Jethro Tull quote you know
Jethro Tull is they say you know what
I'm talking about
one of those corniest musicians
quarterback for the Eagles
[Laughter]
I know it's a band they're saying
Locomotive Breath and Aqualung you know
what I'm talking about band in the
ceremony I know the name but I mean like
yeah yeah it was uh spin me back down
the years and the days of my youth you
were still in your youth chasing your
youth uh this guy's never been in the
present wow yeah and then I wrote
something to my high school girlfriend
you gotta quote never forget you you got
a quote like from your dead bed nearly
that's what that was yeah that's that's
what a 90 year old person who's traveled
the world says yeah you're 18 going
remember the good old days yeah they're
behind me I thought that was it enjoy it
while you I know the Pod was gonna work
out
that was it
uh I don't remember why but I can find
more chicken fingers please you guys got
flatbreads here I think uh I can get him
I know my yearbook's at my is at my
mom's house I can get my hands on it and
find out what it was but it's probably
some shitty lyric or something did you
have one joke no no we never had the
books I mean just a it's a quote yeah oh
no but I would love I'd love to have
something like just
[__] just something up the IRA
[__] the queen that everyone's quote in
Ireland would just be [__] the queen
yeah that would be every single one
and if you didn't do it they'd beat you
up whose side are you on wait you love
the crown now dear what was this some
quote from Bono
uh yeah uh a jersey and a school picture
for an American kid is tough
I think right I don't know I feel like
over there though a soccer jersey would
be acceptable that makes sense I'll give
you that you know no I don't think so I
don't think do you guys wear
s not a pro
here a football jersey to like a wedding
or something is BET where is there
people that do that with like a soccer
you know a soccer jersey they they might
in England with a more any miles they
have no class over there no rules with
those animals
um but they might well because I think
they're more neat they're more in the
sport sure because it's their local
Manchester United yeah yeah as far as I
know I um but uh
yeah you're not supposed to really wear
jerseys too often I think to the game or
watching the game people order your
favorite podcast yeah absolutely well
I'm just my favorite team everyone needs
to know I love Philly guy what do you
want Philly Philadelphia what
neighborhood and Philly are you from
again the
um West Philadelphia that's where I was
born and raised
all right you got me there that worked
this guy checks out thanks FX we got the
letter of recommendation okay you're a
boss
I said Will Smith
uh all right let's see here
um this one this one's from ten dollar
CPAP investor is it garbage or classy to
tint your living room windows my mom did
this in the late 90s
I think I've seen it that's [__] and
I gotta be honest with you I think I
like it what are you in a church
that's the only way you ever been in a
house that had a stained glass window
get the [__] out of here I wouldn't
sleep there to save my life just catch a
cold draft
no I do like the wind I don't mind the
tinted windows it's no you get you get a
sun shade what's a tinted wheel I don't
even know what I did like in a car like
your car it wouldn't be that door you
put it in a car but I don't know what it
is yeah you would just do it like you
would put it on I think I've seen like a
like a film just to stop the you know to
block it a little bit you're not like
they're not like murdered out almost
like in the in the bathroom when they
kind of have a like yeah yeah it's like
a frosted window in their bathroom yeah
maybe I could see that in our old
apartment we uh we got into feeding the
birds on the on the ledge because so the
cat could look at the birds but the cat
the birds kept getting scared away so we
put like a two-way
mirror on it does that make sense so
that when the birds landed they couldn't
look in and see the cat you're that
paranoid you think the birds are looking
at you Jesus Christ they're all robots
try a Xanax pigeon stole my thoughts the
birds are just looking at this Marin
mimo on the other side is the cat just
like the cat say yeah you're so the cat
gets to look at them and coo at them
like it was an interrogation scene yeah
exactly like he's lying get in there
play good good cat back yeah that I
could see but the tinted on that deer
tint in the house I don't think tinting
sound system
[__] subwoofer
my neighbor had a red Mustang and they
put red tints on it
and I thought it was the coolest thing
in the world and looking back sounds
cool it's like something from Cars I
know it was wild I remember you'd be in
it felt like you're in a fishbowl dude
it was [__] it was it was a tough
hang in there you ever see when the
ladies put eyelashes on there on their
cars on the yeah I mean that's trashy
yeah it's a tough look if it's a girl I
dude can't be doing that no I like it
until you know they play ball hey what
are you looking at sweetheart yeah one's
winking yeah but yeah one of your car it
looks like it has a stroke
yeah fender bender is all [__] up
[Laughter]
uh all right let's see this one's from
Galileo is it garbage to be extra sweet
to your to your Elder elderly patients I
guess they work in a hospital and hope
they make a last minute change their to
their will
um I respect the play yeah yeah you got
to do that with uh people in your family
too how you doing Nana you know I would
imagine that probably happens every once
in a while too if they're in like some
type of hospice care or like in a
nursing home and nobody comes to visit
them and they really take care of them
yeah I could see that you hear that
happening too then and then the family
the family gets yeah oh they get mad
they think they like brainwash
them into doing this thing yeah it was
like no you haven't talked to them in
five years so but yeah no that's a good
play I don't know if it's garbage
probably unethical
I don't know frowned the pond at least
some type of HIPAA whatever it is and
then worst case scenario they don't put
you in the wheel you've been nice to
this old person so sure it like
[Laughter]
yeah that's what I think of you I think
of the nicest guy I know sweetheart
Mother Teresa yeah okay sure
uh all right let's see this was from
Brendan is it garbage to keep a sock
full of quarters under your bed for
self-defense I respect that we always
had something oh wait you gotta have
something I feel I feel like a soccer I
feel like I would rip if you'll really
put some velocity on it unless you're
kind of like a shotgun a little Buckshot
my dad always had something next to the
bed it was either like a little one a
little mini bat or he had this like
weird thing that he made and like boy
scouts or something that was a dildo
that was your mom's body I just thought
that would strap around the waist it was
a very unique very unique weapon he had
yeah and we had Intruders a lot I guess
because that was every day I came home
from school he was practicing with my
mom I thought it was French I didn't
know
French golf club uh do you currently
have a weapon at the house or or a
obviously apartments are a little
different you know because it's tougher
to get into but you have some sort of
thing of like I would grab this this is
the knife I would use this is what I'm
grabbing anything like that
I think about I usually I used to have
baseball bats just like by the door yeah
but never use it or anything but uh but
that's actually she's such a big
Phillies fan that's yes that's exactly
why because I'm enjoying the good old
Phillies
we were so unsure about the name
good old I was like feeling I was like
I'll I'll land somewhere
shout out Phillies we love you I love
the feelings all the fighting Phil's
Helium Comedy Club September 20th get
tickets but yeah I think the the coins
are crazy but buy it buy a cue ball
with the coins and the cue ball I think
you get better a little way yeah a
little more velocity that's the most
Irish [__]
you put that money in the bank right and
an IRA account get the interest then you
can buy yourself a knife let's play the
long game on them man a pool ball is
really good I don't I just don't think
you get the the corners oh so you're
gonna cash those coins in eventually
your weapons yes of course I'm trying to
hit a guy with two nickels
[__] I shouldn't have went out last
weekend you got chance for 20.
I'll be right back don't go anywhere
yeah what weapons have you got you
loaded up like
um I got nothing right now I'm playing
it a little too fast and loose in New
York I got a knife that I would never
get to or wake up type of knife how big
are we talking uh just like a little
flip knife oh a little yeah not a
switchblade it's like a regular pocket
knife like an outdoors knife
outdoor knife is CR I don't even know if
I could knife a guy come on you'd have
to seriously coming in the house at you
dude to knife somewhat to stab so that
is a very
intimate yes person you're gonna get
close enough to a guy and then yeah
[__] poke him yeah I'm not saying I
couldn't but that's
I get ran or hit someone with a [__]
dude I have a [__] Glock it's a good
screwing around yeah all right that's a
[__] nickel have a claymore take him
out before he gets in the house okay
let's talk about fitbod I am fitbot I am
fitbot I will destroy you actually they
won't destroy it they'll save you
because gang it's hard to find
motivational workouts in your Fitness
routine is boring so Shake It Up with
fitbot with who the fitbod fitbod fitbot
app is like having a personal trainer in
your pocket it creates custom workouts
based on your goals your experience and
your available equipment uh-huh whether
you have access to a full set of weights
or the heaviest thing in your house is a
can a chicken noodle soup uh-huh fitbot
will create a workout that's exciting
and will get you your best body you ever
had in your life yeah the good Folks at
bitbod allowed us to use it it's easy
peasy you download it they got all the
workouts it keeps it attracts your
muscle fatigue your recovery designs a
well-balanced workout plan for foreign
baby yeah with over 1 000 demo videos
you'll learn how to do the movements the
right way and you can track your
personal best with fitbods progress
charts it's never been easier to get the
results you've always wanted check out
fitbod get 25 off your subscription at
fitbod.me slash garbage that's fitbod
fitbot f-i-t-b-o-d dot me slash garbage
do it gang now back to the gosh darn
show back to the show I'm fitbot did I
tell you the story about the break-in in
my house no I didn't know that oh my god
well this is it's stupid right but so
I'm in my house and we have it in here
yeah so in the kitchen there's a
skylight and birds often land on the
Skylight and they've been scratching it
and stuff like that so I'm lying in bed
I'm hungover as hell I'm with my girl
and we're lying there and I can hear the
birds scratching away and I was like
that was [__]
I'm lying and they're making more noise
and more and I go how funny would it be
if there's someone broke in but uh and
I'm just there thinking it was the birds
the whole time and while I'm thinking
that next thing you know the [__]
door and I'm with my girl in the bedroom
in the bedroom right and then the door
wait the interior door yes yes what
listen get some Michael yeah I'm lying
there right the door opens up and I
immediately go so it's on the other
corner of the bed I jump across the room
like just like like I've never screamed
loud in my life like it was a beer like
it was a wild beer
[Laughter]
you're slipping at something a little
more comfortable I'm not decent I'm not
decent
you're putting powder under your arms
yeah I'm looking for a knife and ball
Gap
so the door opens up right and this
person walks a little black like a
silhouette and I ruined like and I grow
and I and I write the last second I
realize it's like a woman and I stop and
then I realized it was my girlfriend
right she wait what so here's what but
here's what happened when we were asleep
she had gotten up and had a shower but I
thought she was in bed with me you know
you're kind of in and out of asleep okay
and then when she came out of the
bathroom I thought it was a [__]
Intruder so I attacked her coming into
her own bedroom she was like walking out
of the shower opens the door and then
it's just me going
I pinned her up against the wall like
this goes oh my God thank God it's you
who do you work for I know thank God
it's you thank God it's you oh my God
I'm so sorry and then she like she's
Frozen and she just goes
at the lady to cry yeah and then she
goes what are you doing I go oh my God I
tell you on the truth oh my God I'm a
crazy person I thought you were a pigeon
I apologize honestly I thought it was my
landlord I've got this like 90 year old
landlord Little Greek lady and I thought
well you're gonna hit her the reason I
stopped was because I thought it was her
I thought I thought it was an intruder
and then I I thought you were Nancy I
apologize yeah yeah
and she was like texting me later on
even that day like four hours later she
goes like my heart's still racing I
think I need to come home because she
like I almost got put through it I'm
coming home do not attack me I will be
entering the home yeah you gotta Rebel
the ring when she walks in damn dude did
I not tell that I thought I told the
story
crazy yeah there was at least I knew at
least I got the brownie Point she goes
if anyone breaks in you're gonna
immediately attack him sure it was weird
because I jumped as long as it's a woman
in a towel yeah yeah yeah you were
expecting it covered yeah if it was a
big guy I'm like yo this is
right by him
uh damn I would have ran right by you
yeah but I was not that was an intense
one damn that was an intense one that's
crazy yeah I attacked my girlfriend
Oscar Pistorius you know
yikes [__] Vietnam vet
yeah yeah uh all right let's see here
this one's from Richboro Pat here from
the start 10 homie never have one red
shout out to you is a garbage about gas
in your car twice in one day because
you're so jammed up that's okay maybe 10
bucks oh yeah which I've buddy been
there yeah gas to get you to where
you're going I've I've one memorable
time in my life I'm driving home nearly
home had to get gas here or in Ireland
in Ireland no money I put like four
Euros or five euros or something gas is
expensive over there no yeah yeah it's
more is it all diesel petrol no no it's
not diesel now I thought it was diesel
uh it's some diesel I guess not all
diesel
are you from Ireland
yes I want to work with you on this one
yeah yeah I think you're a [__]
attorney yes don't you but you are dumb
electric cars over there petrol means
gasoline no I know but I thought they
used diesel I thought it was the
countries do I mean Germany Germany's a
lot of diesel okay there you go yeah so
I I they're different countries though
tight but I left I left the gas station
petrol station and the light went on as
soon as I left sure while I drove out
the light was like the light took a
break for a minute and then went
straight back on go down a hill you're
[__] yeah I've never filled the car up
with all the money I had in the world
and the gas the light was still on yeah
because you know when that's when you
know you're in a bad place when you know
exactly how many miles you can get out
of that life sure there you go I've got
I can I can sure yeah you're flying too
close to the Sun if you know you're
living a you're living a very
I didn't start saying fill it up until
about a year ago oh I'm the same way
like 11 months ago maybe it was always
20 on this 30 on that 40 on that yeah
part of me doesn't like waiting too I'm
like just give me 20. I'm just going
here let me just [__] get out of here
uh dude there it is fill it up feels
good there it is yeah I feel like the
car drives better when it's on a full
tank everyone's happy whistling yeah
yeah your problems all melt away he
wants that [__] light girl turns off
dude there is nothing I used my I had a
real shitty Chevy Lumina was my first
car and I would put you know five bucks
would get me a quarter of a tank at the
time and I was always rolling on E uh
and dude there was nothing more
devastating than having like three you
know doing like three bucks or something
oh yeah we're buying like a pack of cigs
I'm like hey put the rest on sure pump
three and it was like 317 or whatever
and you see a Snickers you're like yeah
you got it you gotta get the six because
yeah if you're
[Laughter]
it's cold out there
these guys thinking that and dude
starting the car and the thing not even
moving is like so disheartening you're
like [__] cause in your head you're like
all my problems are gonna go away and
you're just sitting there like oh man
I'm still stuck in reality
somebody asked this a couple weeks ago I
can't remember it was about uh
putting oil and there was a while where
every time I went to the gas station and
got gas I had to put [__] a little
oil in the car too to keep it because
there was a leak or something it was a
leak I might in my car in my first Chevy
Lumina I didn't know you
I didn't know what this is going to
sound bad I didn't know what an oil
change was I didn't know you were
replacing the oil replacing the oil in
the car I always just had to add oil
do my car yeah does that make sense like
I never took it to a Jiffy Lube to get
the oil I would just go to Exxon and buy
like oh I'm low
I would just let it burn all out and
then I'd be like Oh I'm low and I'd have
to put more in [__] your engine up oh is
that not it is that not the thing no
you're supposed to go get a chain oil
change they completely empty it and then
they put they put fresh oil in there I
would just let it burn all out and then
add it let's [__] up your engine oh you
could feel it dude it would start going
I'd be like I gotta I gotta get to an
Exon and [__] top this bad boy off
well then I guess I I guess you'll learn
something new sure oil and transmission
fluid none of that stuff one of the one
of the biggest things I heard from uh it
was actually a pretty scumbag uh used
car salesman be like pop the hood when I
was like looking at used cars or
whatever and he goes you have to you
have to constantly check the things that
are clear if you pop the hood all the
tanks that are clear
all so you can see the the uh levels
okay transmission fluid has a clear
thing does it yes the oil doesn't but
the transmission fluid should just the
wiper fluid the transmission too I has
it I believe there's a gun really all
right unless I was lying to me now that
I'm saying it out loud it sounds like an
idiot I feel like I've never been in a
car before it's all diesel
yeah that's all a couple of real car
guys yeah now that I'm saying I'm like
well you can't see the oil you can't see
anything now I'm [__] you can't see
the gas man this guy [__] lied to me
here opening the radiator yes I saw one
of those explode in the guy's face one
time my neighbor [__] you up did a
[__] he was they were leaning over
and it popped all over his face and he
ran and jumped in above ground pool when
I was a kid every every week when I was
a kid every winter somebody would show
up to school with [__] uh burns from
the radiator on their face like in the
houses oh look they were like yeah
playing by the radiator we were always
taught don't go into the [__]
radiator every every year somebody would
come in with a [__] splatter burn on
their face you guys have heat in Ireland
no honestly like yeah not really really
no you had radiators yeah we do but like
we're not made of money
simple people what was the primer put on
a jacket and then shut the [__] up what
was the primary source of heating in
your home as a kid does my dad yelling
[Laughter]
running around trying to avoid the
[__] fists that's not working taco
Tuesdays you're gonna warm you up right
there
no you know what we had we had um
we have hot water bottles which is you
know hot water bottle sure yeah so you'd
feel like a just a bottle I guess with
boiling water and then you put in the
bed get the [__] out of here you're not
damn Civil War
we had them I still I still use it when
I go home yeah we might go to put
someone in the bed I got thanks man wait
a minute wait a minute there's no heat
in the house it's freezing it's free in
my house in Ireland it is freezing but
there has to be some sort of there is an
ability to put on the heat which is what
electric
um it's got to be a radiator yeah yeah
it's radiator okay yeah it's water they
fill up from the gas or the oil right
it's a big oil tank that they have at
the backyard
I've never been there yeah it's yeah
it's the oil it heats the water is it
probably a furnace in the furnace yeah
like that yeah that makes sense or the
furnace heat space yeah we sound like
[__] idiots yeah this is also if I
didn't know years ago I've been almost
like wait no one's ever asked me you're
guessing too I know I did know it at one
point yeah but they didn't turn the heat
on a lot they still don't I go home now
it's freeze I can see my breath and like
the house is freezing because we had a
cold stone and we like uh we like get
drier clothes on the washing line and
stuff like that so it was like you just
have to wait until the weather's good
because what year is it there
man with the Industrial Revolution it's
Ireland you guys are gonna love it dude
you know what it is my parents I forget
the internet over there 80s I guess
eight all Trail Islands history has been
pretty much the Great Depression so like
they're the people I grew up with
they're just like you know you know if
you burnt your toast you got to scrape
it off there's no such thing as I know
that's those yeah okay we're not the
royal family yeah I'll scrape it if you
think I've never scraped a piece of
toast put the burnt toast under your
pillow keep you warm
yeah stomach cramps are like an injury I
think yeah but I remember when I was
young so this is before they invented
the
okay I don't think it is this is before
they invented I'm sure there's people in
Ireland listening right now be like
where does this guy live what is he he
live under a rock
seriously like a like a Nickelodeon
cartoon dude did you talk about it like
it's a third world gun do you were
hanging your laundry out in the winter
so this was before they invented the the
water bottle sleeve so there's like a
furry kind of a sleeve sure you put the
water bottle in it's nice back in the
day it was just straight on that road
straight rubber yeah that would burn you
straight off because you you'd put it on
you'd get in and it was like
scald your leg Yeah I remember I fell
asleep once and burnt my ass I burnt my
ass I fell asleep on the [__] sitting
on the water bottle so she get her sleep
with a thermos dude I know I fell asleep
burnt my ass woke up I had to get like
hey we got a hot bag of water I can
sleep with
I have to get some sort of netting type
of thing put on my ass some sort of like
a third degree burn type thing they're
called underwear
fishnets all right
we don't have all that underwear we had
a coal stove is what we used back in the
day what yeah cold stuff it was cold
he's not gonna know what that is you
know what coal is oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah fine nice put it in
there we had cold you real young I think
real younger then but everyone had colds
made the place nice and toasty oh yeah
when we grew up it was a black smoke
flying from all over and then it became
like an Eco system [__] thing where
they're like get rid of the battery
environment
right sure I'm really painting this guy
dude I'm like I have a picture of your
house in my head from your previous
episodes as well and it changes every
two seconds we gotta change the name of
the show are you stupid
I used to have a cold car actually back
in there imagine like Ellis Island right
yeah you're talking about see-through
cars
he's sleeping with hot water bottles
heat what is he
ah God all right Jesus Christ we are a
couple of [__] idiots
um
this is from Tracy what is the lowest
Stakes game you've ever witnessed that
if that ended up in a fight I saw 250
year olds properly square up over a
Skee-Ball dispute on the Ocean City
boardwalk in 2001 2004. that makes sense
though uh I mean we've gotten we've we
would have like game nights when we were
like in our 20s and drinking like our
cousins and stuff like oh we're all down
the shore let's play [__] you know
what were those games that hit there was
a
Apples to Apples there was like a couple
of those Cards Against Humanity Against
Humanity all that kind of not Boggle
Brain Quest or whatever there was a
bunch of [__] we would do that when we
played guns when we were kids you know
you play guns yeah and like if somebody
wouldn't go down like I shot you now
yeah it wouldn't go down yeah that would
start off oh yeah yeah like like tag or
something like you didn't get me yeah it
was always one [__] [__] kid yeah
yeah it was always like a friend of a
friend or like somebody on the fringes
like you didn't get me [__] I got you
start swinging oh yeah well we do we
would have we'd be adults playing and it
would end in like near fist fights
because you're drinking you're boozing
you're like anything where the rules are
up for debate is and there's booze
involved is bad news like Scrabble
what's a real word [__] is a word John
three T's in a row yeah
huh that's tough I try to stay beer pong
always ends in a
argument a lot because that's it it's
over you know the competition and then
the booze involved it you know also
Everybody Plays different roles and
stuff like that where is beer pong
probably not it's no it is now because
of the internet but it wasn't when I was
growing up it wasn't like a pop it
wasn't a thing yeah I believe it is now
more people are getting involved just
drinking drinking games weren't really
that big I don't think in Ireland
compared to here
yeah we're just all boozing all the time
anyway I guess we haven't seen that
[__] up we had a thing called Kings
for a while yeah
so Kings is uh it's a card every card
has a rule yeah and then and and some of
the rules are just like if you get three
you gotta pour like three seconds of
your drink into this big cup in the
middle and okay very end whoever gets
the fourth King has to drink the
whatever whatever's in the middle and
everyone everyone's been pouring in
their stuff but you get waste if whoever
loses that or that looks like you get a
five you gotta drink your drink for five
seconds yeah you can like give out like
oh I won't call him to drink for 10
seconds or whatever I like that yeah get
real [__] up yeah that was like why
was one of the first games we learned in
high school aside from beer pong was
Kings can you guys play dominoes you
don't play dominoes no no I mean it
doesn't make any sense to me which is
cool though I saw it and I live in the
Heights so it's uh there's a it's a lot
of it's a Dominican neighborhood so they
all play out on the streets and like
they watch like watching it seems so
boring to like because I don't
understand
it's like watching a board game yeah you
know what I mean it's they're enthralled
by it gotta get a table figure yeah set
up shop you play dominoes [__] no set
them up knock them down pretty good
though yeah that's what I thought Domino
what isn't that Domino's no it's it's
it's I don't know what the numbers the
numbers put them together is this set up
we're sounding more stupid why the [__]
does this keep happening
let's get some the Greeks playing out
there in Astoria too they'll play
dominoes yeah you'll just get a couple
of old widowers sitting in their Garden
playing dominoes playing dominoes that
bridge and pinochle I never understood
peanut I know Gin Rummy
I could do a little Gin Rummy yeah
that's easy I don't know what bridge is
burn your Bridges
I thought I was like this like old like
old person game yeah it is they play
bridge pinochle doesn't pinochle have
its own deck there's a Pinochle deck
it always made me hungry when I would
say that word pinochle why I don't know
because it reminds you a peanut brittle
something yeah that's what I think yeah
people playing cards of peanut butter
and one thing I do know is a nice piece
of peanut brittle I love it dude I
remember I we were we went away for like
a weekend like in the Poke like up in
the mountains or something and I was in
charge of bringing the cards I was like
I'm like I got a deck of cards I bought
a set of b-knuckle cards and it's all
checks and it's all Jackson Kings dude
and we started playing dude we started
playing [__] Blackjack and everybody
was getting 20s and 21s I'm like I was I
think I was the house too I'm like I'm
getting [__] Bamboozled over here
winner winner chicken dinner hippies out
three grand you scammed yourself yeah oh
nice
fool me one shame on me man I had the
hot hand dealing though
uh all right let's hear this one's from
Kyle uh is it garbage dip your potato
chips into ketchup it's like a crispy
french fry I defer to the Big Man on
this I would say no I mean but it seems
like something you would get down on the
salty sweet I get do they [__] with that
over there Colin on your crisps oh yeah
we love cat a lot of ketchup yeah a lot
of ketchup on your chip like your potato
chips yeah of course ketchup on your
chips I've never crisps crisps yeah I've
never heard of it
um but I guess in theory you know fry
same yeah this is the way I look at it
when you don't hate it when you're
younger and you're hungry you're in the
house we've talked about this you start
experimenting a little bit sure you do
some things that you know you might not
normally do and it's not crazy it's a
potato it's a it's basically a french
fry it's not you talk about it it is
it's a potato potatoes and ketchup
historically go well together what's the
[__] difference it depends on what
type of flavor the the chip is like
straight chip like a plan change they do
have ketchup flavor chips they do have
ketchup and they also have cottage fries
which are basically just thick potato
chips I don't see anything wrong with it
I've never done it but I can't [__] I
don't know it's wrong I can't explain
why it doesn't feel right I think all
right here's my astute observation it
works with a french fry because they're
bigger and there's a dipping most chips
chips are small and you're greasy in
your finger it's like you're there's got
a couple of chips in your hand a little
ketchup but then but then for the French
onion dip in a chip is fantastic
yes it is
way and yeah the chip in a french onion
dip is that what you said yeah yeah
dipping chips and french onion dip yeah
but that's not what I'm talking about
but that's not a dip ketchup's not a dip
I think it certainly could be okay
ketchup is not a dip what's the
difference between condiments and a dip
a dip is is a sub section of content
and there's been a bowl of ketchup
but you got it with your fry sometimes
it comes out on that little side little
little Ramekin that's a condom and you
dip it in there a dip is consists of
multiple condiments I would argue that I
would say ketchup consists of multiple
things as well it's not a dip I think he
was on your side and you just wanted you
just made up an argument to go with it
Tomatoes spices whose team are you on
here man are you with me yeah dude oh
yeah all right
screw you guys but it's not a dip it's
not a dip what I'll bring ketchup if
someone goes I'll bring the dips and
they showed up with mayonnaise and
ketchup take them out of your house yeah
I'm at salsan
some helmets Yeah Yeah just because you
can dip doesn't make it a dip you can
physically yes yes what so you can dip a
fry in ketchup but ketchup's not a dip
yes I'm saying it isn't it he's saying
it is it's not a dip I know you don't
put a dip on a sandwich as a condom yeah
it's not saying you can't but you don't
how do you feel about this when you get
a sandwich against it and then instead
of giving you fries you get chips I
don't hate it I don't feel it it doesn't
fulfill me with a sandwich
sometimes it bothers me because I want
the fries but I like it's classy a nice
lunch a nice light lunch a little sure a
little light lunch they do chips with
the wings at the cellar it knows that's
perfect a homemade chip a homemade chip
with like a burger if they're like the
real thick one I don't know okay would
you dip a homemade chip and ketchup
uh
yes okay now we're getting somewhere now
that's in the middle that's more fry
than chip
I don't know you do know and you don't
want to give it to me no okay as long as
we're all in the same page here but
let's get some chips
it's kind of frowned upon or something
there's something not right about it but
I can't figure out why it would be nuts
to all right look at it this way ketchup
should go on things with fries you could
sprinkle it on the top of fries you
would never have a plate of chips and
sprinkle ketchup on it I might yeah no
because you would have what do you mean
you might I have I'm not saying that you
wouldn't yeah well you're not yeah
you're spreading ketchup all across a
big big family bowl of chips Oh no
just go like the guy who's like the
lemon on the oyster yeah guys I'll get
this does the ketchup on that no I'll do
the toppings for everybody if it was
good for ketchup right
I'm safe to assume everybody wants some
uh hold on that's a that's something to
ponder let's say there's a thing of
fries this is the only show we can
ponder this for [__] eight minutes I
like what you're saying let's say
there's a thing of fries that you got
for the table is it proper to hit all
over the fries or do you make the pool
you gotta make
[Music]
okay here I always look at a little it
depends on the the nozzle it depends on
the application of the ketchup if it's
one of the fine squirt ones you can
drizzle gentlemen I'll give you a drill
you can't glob a hole it's got to be the
you got to be able to Spritz it nobody's
using those bottles anymore
what the old glass bottles they said
black them out like that you gotta whack
them out yeah really yeah what the [__]
are you eating they refill them though
that's that's not fresh ketchup that's
like just wow oh yeah the Heinz these
are yeah they bought Heinz once in the
game yes it was an investment purchase
there's probably still some at the
bottom of it that they never get to the
worst was grown up and you get to the
bottom of us and you have to get your
knife in and it would like your finger
it'd be almost like your fingers would
come out covered and ketchup you know
and you can to get that last bit brutal
but I don't think that's great if table
fries you can't just put your stuff you
gotta have a vote and goes everywhere
yeah you gotta vote I'm sure yeah my mom
would put a little water in the bottle
and Shake It Off yeah like shampoo
I know
we've all been there man there was
nothing worse than [__] getting in
there and spraying it and they're being
cold water from like the day before Oh
in the shower cold Suds in the shower
that'll wake you up baby man and that
[__] sucked I hated that hmm all
right gang we got a wrap her up call him
Turtle 30 minutes of Colin Turtle it's
out on his YouTube page right now
September 20th as I think we might have
mentioned he's going to be an alien
comedy club in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
yes can I just say one thing if you do
anything if you do watch the special and
because of this show just leave a little
comment and say something like garbage
or just say go Phillies or whatever you
want to do tell him the bozos do a
little tracking yeah it's nice spider
where the traffic
he's gonna call me this [__] in four
days like you only got two [__]
comments that will be
it is worth it
it's a pleasure man can't be what do you
got for him guys we're all over the road
tickets are on sale uh uh the first leg
of the stores is starting this week or
yeah I can't wait in a couple days so
Phoenix there's still some tickets left
a little left in the second show in
Denver La is pretty much sold out some
at the second show in San Diego Salt
Lake City get those tickets the show's
selling out don't [__] miss out guys
and December we'll be in Philly at the
Fillmore we added a second show December
20th get tickets for that yes gang we
[__] love it to death and we'll see
you next week peace